and put the call out to anyone yeah to
send you stuff fourth-of-july you're
building a documentary what do you hope
you get back I hope that we get footage
back that is inspiring I know we've
gotten back footage because we've seen
it we haven't seen all of it yet because
we're buried in it yeah but we did we
shot a film on a single day July 4th
2017 in every state in the United States
of America plus Puerto Rico Puerto Rico
and DC 24-hours a portrait of our
country down there and I thought it was
just a really important time to tell our
story and it's insane yeah what happens
in 24 hours and we have the birth of the
child we have the passing of someone we
have the most incredible and insane
footage you could ever imagine
I'm wondering when a you know rock star
actor Hollywood sends out the call to
America you may get stuff back that
maybe you don't agree with politically
maybe you don't agree with morally yeah
will that be included yeah absolutely we
we have some surprises and we see points
of views that are maybe much different
than your own but I you can't really
tell an accurate portrait or you can't
paint an accurate portrait unless you
include all sides so it's an a political
portrait and then we ask people from all
over the world to send in their thoughts
what does America mean to you sure what
is the American dream mean to you so
it's it's a compelling piece the the
album and the themes of the album
directly relate to the film and the
music
is the soundtrack to this film that we
made when it comes to making music you
haven't collaborated extensively in the
past no do you want to collaborate is
that a plan is that on the new record is
yeah I've only collaborated one once
before we have as a band thirty Seconds
to Mars collaborated with Kanye West and
it was incredible he was fantastic and
we ended up performing together in Spain
in front of 60,000 people but it was it
was a really fun I'd love to do it again
yeah yeah I find that because Canadian
artists that we can pull in tons of
Canadian yeah who do you think okay
they're the normal ones I personally for
me I think thirty Seconds to Mars in the
weekend would kill it incredible he's
super talent and yeah lovely like that
would just be like a pretty explosive
yeah right yeah when you do you find
that you're in a different position than
other sort of celebs because they tend
to the the story is always you don't
know what the world is like because
you're only New York and Los Angeles but
in a touring band you go to smaller
towns you travel America do you feel
that you have a different relationship
with those people who criticize
Hollywood I think that it's okay to
criticize Hollywood yeah that's not such
a bad thing I think that when we do that
we're taking a look at ourselves you
know and and also certain parts of
ourselves that we may not agree with
whether it's you know excess or
indulgence and that's okay you know we
can we can take it but we when you are
in a band and you travel from
Poughkeepsie to Pittsburgh to San
Francisco to Texas to Kazakhstan to Oman
to South Africa to Brazil to whatever
you do get a sense of the world that's
unique I mean you have a you have a
perspective in it
and it teaches you about things that you
may not have known otherwise so I'm
really grateful that I have had that
exposure you know we've been coming to
Toronto I remember 1998 we played the
horseshoe yeah right and you know to
this day we have a really special
relationship with the city we've played
here so many times over the years and
the years and the years that it's it's
changed the way that we see this town
and the way we feel about it and we've
gotten to know the people of Canada from
extensive tours here in a really unique
way have you seen the new Blade Runner
trailer I haven't seen the new Blade
Runner trailer yet I'm waiting you're
waiting until what I'm waiting I'm
waiting do you watch your own stuff you
know mushrooms I don't tend to watch my
own stuff than what was it I like was it
awesome is it a good flavor I was
incredible yeah it was a dream it was a
dream for me Blade Runner is one of the
best films of all time and one of my
favorite films I go back to it all of
the time yeah and it taught me so much
about cinematography about directing
about acting about storytelling about
music and you know I always encourage
people I know it I haven't seen the
movie to watch the movie so being a part
of this new chapter incredibly exciting
working with Harrison and to me and Ryan
all these incredible people was
fantastic and you know I'm on tour now
and I'm finishing my album now so I'm
not as much not you know as much a part
of the process with some of the stuff
but you know like but when you dipped
into that world would you do Joker again
have you been asked that to come back to
that world you know talking about Joker
is like talking about Fight Club I
unless you want to you know
gargle your testicles it's probably
better to leave it yeah he's liable to
jump out of the cupboard and just you
know start having fun fair enough and
believe me if there's anybody who knows
what happens when you talk about Fight
Club okay let's eat
first of all it's the first rule thank
you so much